hallo ich meine lieben frau kathy fear
combat aircraft fries zu dem neben
vielen dingen als in der letzten folge
beim marx haben wir hier die höhle
wissen der kunde und ich habe ein bild
gemacht nein ich habe noch einen
weiteren standen zugefügt wir hören
luca entdeckt das klatschen finden
ja ich gebe es noch einen gang runter
ich möchte einfach mal auch mal meine
ersten diamanten jetzt finden
irgendwann ist gar nicht so schwer sein
was mich einfach weg kapitel an dingen
an markt bauen oder ja aber ich habe
jetzt eine riesen geyer höhlen
wir müssen irgendwo diamanten sein alter
eher freude das kann nicht sein ich lauf
hier unten schon die ganze zeit her
grübel habe ich zwar schon ein bisschen
gefunden aber diamanten sind einfach
bisher so eine fehlanzeige
sollte es mal nicht läuft wir sogar an
den ängsten laverton pässen her wenn ich
manchmal einfach kein essen und schon
wieder ein super hier bei uns auf dem
weiher fragt verbrannte mandl verbrachte
mandeln safety ehrlich direkt ab ich hab
irgendwie schon bei den 30 kartoffeln
ja ich weiß nicht ob junge hier sind
halt nur creeper dieser höhle
weil ich zu viel mit spitzen besser für
mich weil ich mich schützen
komm du bist und nirgendwo wir nehmen es
verbrannte mandl mit ja komm jetzt viel
zu tief runter da ich habe gesagt ich
muss man erst mal aber nein ja keine
rüstung gut bewegen das schon richtig
soll ich dir in bogen mit ja
sterben und etwas zu essen
ich kenne mich bringt verbrachte man die
kraft
ich habe so viele geile sache dabei auf
wie sich laura die hier findest du mich
nicht hast du hingelaufen will hier
geht's runter kommen damit jetzt zeigt
ihr wart ich muss auch etwas essen ein
bisschen proviant auf 5 wartet gar nicht
hier kommen damit weiter weiter weiter
schnell schnell schnell hier jetzt
hinter mir gut jetzt mal hier hoch und
spaßtag lover oder so unterschiedliche
reifen ein junger ich will einfach nur
guck was ich hier für die höhle gefunden
aber leider alltäglich bei dias finden
sind die wachen spiel sturm wo bist du
gestorben
hier irgendwo europas opfers aussagen
feuerwehr oder der kripo jetzt pass auf
die linke sagt ein händler
kinderspaß feuerwehr direkt die nicht
als die aufnahme haben den proviant
zunächst den weg und wurden nun möchte
er will jetzt tötete immer wenn ich
laufe nur noch ein gewissen diamanten
seien die mit mir verbunden werden
wollen mit ihr verbunden werden die mich
lieben junge das kann halt nicht sein
ich muss jetzt mal irgendwie die
arbeiten finden
können wir teilen sie ok ja sonst hätte
ich sie gefunden
es war wahnsinnig fleißig trolley die
ganze zeit herum seit zwei folgen
einfach untragbar männer cameron diaz du
willst du wie sollen wir hier raus
finden
durch die wand nein ja ich weiß ich hab
sogar ochs bonner gefunden
ja ich hätte es auch noch gefunden so
schnell oder wie gott oh gott ich sind
zu viele machst mich nehmen halt einfach
halt alle sachen mit ich sehe dich wir
kommen hier nicht hin kommen wir nicht
in fahrt komme ich dahin luca ehrlich
nicht du bist sowas von verrecken
die sind echt zu viele mops nur langsam
das habe ich schon so lange nicht mehr
gesehene meine kraft aber ich bin so
genial ich mache jetzt einfach so mock
beim six pack ich mir alle weg tätiger
ich habe ja auch wieder viel zu haben
ist am start unbesiegt die mit dem
ausbau ihrer kunden vielleicht findet
ihr ein sattel oder sonst hätte ja das
kann doch nicht sein
ich laufe wieder eine lava in person er
nirgendwo wurden cameron einmal hoch
vielleicht finden wir irgendwas coolest
du dass die kisten öffnen wenn du magst
ich gucke ich nicht rein wenden wenn du
jetzt kommt ok ich komme immer wieder
eine mutter
verkauft oder sambia verein scheiße ja
nur vier sattel von lucy krieg hälfte
von denen ich gewinne
dafür ist ja ja ich weiß nicht ich kann
halt richtig wenig nur noch mitnehmen in
meinen taschen voll gold quadrate mit
ins bonner ausgeleuchtet
sollten sie es immer merken ich mache es
dann von peter fox aus niederen meinen
taschen voll gold keine ahnung welches
die spitzenteams der rest der christen
ist es für dich dass in österreich
höhere alter wie viele gute sachen so
ungefähr circa 20 es gibt halt nur zwei
auswahlmöglichkeiten sogar so nett und
haben pastinaken geheime botschaft
gefolgt alter du nimmst du nimmst sattel
und pferderücken nicht mit
ich brauche ich eine ich hatte echt
stadt bekommen in moskau ist auch ein
aber ich muss mir noch eine spitze
gemacht hat meinen machen also mitte
dadurch könnten aber nicht allein suchen
hey hey wichtig dass er leider eben man
richtig nicht
kinder wenn ich noch mehr sachen
mitnehmen irgendwie hier sind halt
richtig viele aufgeschreckt
wir sind schon viele sachen aber da ist
ganz viel glück
ja aber ich hab mal station fortan noch
nicht und ich kann nur so viel mit wie
geht wegen weg ist leicht da der stein
ich entspreche der straße landwehr
lustige runde und indirekt zwei dir also
zwei bier quälen weil sie nicht sein
denkmal wisst ihr nachfragen sind sicher
scheint gleich wieder die us sammeln
die ganzen anderen auch noch mitnehmen
das schaffe platz
ich hab jetzt ordentlich lass uns noch
irgendwie ich will noch therapie willst
du fährt haben uns wieder für mich ich
kann das alles verloren
ich habe alles verloren in lava auf noch
junge gedacht meinen sachen ich wollte
so gerne fährt haben schade jetzt habe
ich nicht mehr weiter was eine chance
junge ich würde nicht als echt an einer
stelle umbringen wenn ich in lava
gestorben wäre ich bin noch weiter
aufstocken
und wenn du kaufen steht bringt mich
auch nochmal macht es mir egal ist also
zumindest das problem ich mir dass du
herausfinden musste aber ich habe auch
drei ich hab das pferde sattel und
fördere den rat gegeben
in real life mein kummer hier sprich ich
bringe zudem sehe mich zu erträgen
könnte alles alles voll mit bembel
richtig traurig egal ich war sogar
ziemlich
mehr aber noch an
gewerkschafter ertrank übrigens gerade
dann komme ich nach hause und ist die
volksschüler vorbei wenn ich zu hause
bin denke ich manchmal frage beantworten
kann er machen wenn ihr euch eine sache
wünschen könnte egal wie teuer ist was
wäre diese muss aber viel kann ich in
raten bezahlt krieg später idealen kaste
muss erstmal hypothek aufnehmen das
nämlich bändigen kann ständigen doch
kostenlos die sache hypothek bibliothek
nicht kostenlos
nein aber das war noch die frage werden
wenn es nichts karten kosten würde
jung ich lasse mir das gesagt sein
ja ich bin grad fast wieder zu hause ich
suche jetzt eben den weg noch weiß ich
nicht ich will mir halt echt richtig
gern mal ein richtig cooles auto kaufen
das halt echt mal gemeinden weg ist
ruhig auf meine weise sondern auto ist
halt schon kann schon teuer werden so
richtig coole autos so traumautos von
mir kosten halt schon so 60.000 aufwärts
und hab ich ja kein geld heraus zu geben
soll
deswegen auto denke denke ich wenn ich
dafür kein geld bezahlen müsste wenn ich
auch cool nachmachen
dachte just fahrrad rasten oder urlaub
in verkehrs mesz auf englisch da war
nichts mehr lose ziehen um so viel ich
kann etwas abgeben
nur sie ist süße hätten wir nicht die
diamanten brüderlich geteilt dann hätten
wir es gar keine
also hätte hätte ich jetzt ganz bewusst
dass der staat jetzt nicht stürzt du
erst mal wieder so ein krieg können ihre
pisten schon wieder drei der welt egal
wo ich bin meiner bruder also erstmal
alles in die kiste packen
bordeaux [ __ ] ich dachte die studios
setzen
was bin ich wieder fällig ich bin
richtig konzentriert desto kleiner nach
vier herzen kopflose kopfloser nick oder
kommt da nix kaputt
eine spinne zwei herzen weil ich habe
alles geschafft ich bin jetzt zu hause
und ich würde sagen freude wenn euch
diese junge pastor auf hier schnell
irgendwie weg steht direkt vor meiner
bude
was fehlt dir ein alter erlaubt uns
einfach aus mir zu sagen oder nein lacht
ich so meine lieben freunde ich würde
sagen wenn euch diese folge gefallen hat
diese sehr actionreiche folge dann würde
ich definitiv ich glaube die ganze unter
der face cavalli so tief gesessen will
ich mich über eine bewertung freuen
schaut beim eck vorbei mächtig irgendwo
unten ganz unten in der beschreibung als
tänzer verlinkt geredet und dann würde
ich sagen ja